GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO "FOX
NEWS PRIMETIME," I'M WILL CAIN.
BRET JUST MENTIONED THAT HIS
FAVORITE CHRISTMAS SONG WAS
WHITE CHRISTMAS.
I HATE TO BREAK IT TO HIM IF YOU
ARE DREAMING OF A WHITE
CHRISTMAS, YOU MIGHT BE A
RACIST.
OF COURSE, I'M TALKING ABOUT
SNOW.
BUT AMERICA CAN'T ESCAPE THE
FRAMEWORK OF SKIN COLOR BECAUSE
INSTEAD OF SPREADING CHEER AND
JOY THIS HOLIDAY SEASON, BLACK
LIVES MATTER IS ASKS ITS
FOLLOWERS TO PARTICIPATE IN
SEGREGATION.
THEY CALL THEIR MISSION BLACK
XMAS AND IT'S GOAL IS PRETTY
SIMPLE FIGHT WHITE SUPREMACIST
CYST CAPITALIST.
YOU ARE PROBABLY WONDERING WHAT
IS WHITE SUPREMACIST CAPITALISM
AND THAT IS ALSO SIMPLE, IT'S
ANY BUSINESS OWNED BY A WHITE
PERSON IF YOU WANT TO CELEBRATE
BLACK XMAS STAY AWAY FROM WHITE
SUPREMACIST STORES AND SHOP
EXCLUSIVELY AT BLACK-OWNED
BUSINESSES.
BLM WILL CALL YOU A RACIST NOT
SHOPPING AT STORES FROM PLAQUE
PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE NO PROBLEM IN
ACCEPTING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
DONATIONS FROM COMPANIES THEY
CONSIDER WHITE SUPREMACISTS.
COBLEG, WILL GOOGLE, THEY LINED
UP TO GIVE BLACK LIVES MATTER
MILLIONS.
BLM HAPPILY ACCEPTED.
RAISED MORE THAN $90 MILLION
WHERE IT WENT AND WHAT PURPOSE
THAT MONEY WENT?
NOT TOO SURE.
WE KNOW IT DIDN'T GO TO HELP ANY
BLACK PEOPLE, UNLESS YOU COUNT
THE CO-FOUNDER OF BLM BOUGHT
FOUR MANSIONS AFTER HER
NONPROFIT RAKED IN ALL THAT
CASH.
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED THAT BLACK
LIVES MATTER IS FULL OF
HYPOCRITES WHO WILL TAKE MONEY
FROM COMPANIES AT THE I CONSIDER
TO BE WHITE SUPREMACISTS WHILE
TELLING COKE, HOW DO THEY FEEL
ABOUT SEGREGATED SHOPPING.
WELL, THEY HAVE BEEN SILENT SO
FAR.
AND, LOOK, I CAN BE LOGICAL, I
CAN FOLLOW THE LEFT'S RULES.
SILENCE?
WELL, THAT'S COMPLICIT, THE
TRUTH IS BLACK LIVES MATTER AND
THOSE THAT ENABLE THAT RADICAL
GROUP HAVE MORE IN COMMON WITH
EUGENE BULL CONNER THAN THEY DO
MARTIN LUTHER KING.
YOU CAN NEVER WHIP THESE BIRDS
IF YOU DON'T KEEP YOU AND THEM
SEPARATE.
I FOUND THAT OUT IN BIRMINGHAM.
YOU HAVE GOT TO KEEP YOUR WHITE
AND THE BLACK SEPARATE.
>> YOU KNOW, RETURNING TO THE
SEGREGATED LUNCH COUNTER IS UGLY
ENOUGH AND EVERY MORAL AMERICAN
SHOULD SHOUT IT DOWN THERE IS
EVEN MORE TO THIS STORY BECAUSE
BLACK XMAS IS PART OF SOMETHING
MUCH LARGER AND PRANCE EVEN MORE
DANGEROUS.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW PUSHING
SOMETHING CALLED RACIAL EQUITY
AUDITS COMING SOON TO AN
EMPLOYER NEAR YOU.
THEY ARE STARTING WITH AMERICA'S
TECH COMPANIES.
IT PROPOSES THESE AUDITS OF
FINDING BUSINESSES $20,000 A DAY
IF THEY REFUSE TO COMPLY.
COMPLY WITH WHAT?
THEY SAY PROMOTING RACIAL
JUSTICE.
BUT IT ACTUALLY DOES THE EXACT
OPPOSITE.
HERE'S HOW.
ONE POPULAR PART OF THIS AUDIT
CALLS FOR ABOLISHING THE
DEFINITION OF MERIT SO THEY CAN,
QUOTE ATTRACT BLACK TALENT.
NOW, HOW IS THAT?
AS IF BLACK PEOPLE CAN'T MEET
CURRENT STANDARDS?
I KNOW THAT'S RACIST.
YOU KNOW THAT'S RACIST.
WHY KNOW THAT BLATANTLY RACIST
AND SO DO THEY.
WHY ARE THEY PUSHING THEE AUDITS
TO TAKE CONTROL OF CORPORATE
AMERICA.
THE AUDITS ARE USUALLY PERFORMED
BY OUTSIDE GROUPS WITH, GET
THIS:  CLOSE TIES TO DEMOCRATS
AND GEORGE SOROS.
WHEN THEY SAY THEY ARE LOOKING
TO PROMOTE DIVERSITY EQUITY AND
INCLUSION IN REALITY THEY'RE
USING AUDITS TO MOVE OPERATIVES
INTO TOP POSITIONS IN POWERFUL
TECH COMPANIES IN ORDER TO DO
THEIR BIDDING.
LISTEN TO THE PRESIDENT OF A
LEFT WING ORGANIZATION ENTITLED
COLOR OF CHANGE RASHAD ROBINSON
HE TESTIFIED IN FRONT OF
CONGRESS LAST WEEK AND HE CALLED
FOR INDEPENDENT AUDITORS TO
REVIEW NEW PRODUCTS FROM TECH
COMPANIES BEFORE THEY'RE RELEASE
TO THE PUBLIC.
THIS GIVES AUDITORS, OF COURSE,
CARTE BLANCHE, FINAL SAY OVER
TECHNOLOGY WE ARE ALLOWED TO
USE.
SO ARE TECH COMPANIES OPEN TO
TAKING ORDERS FROM RADICAL
GROUPS?
IT SEEMS SO.
THE WASHINGTON FREE BEACON
REPORTS IN 2018 COLOR OF CHANGE
SUCCESSFULLY PUSHED FACEBOOK
INTO COMPLETING AN AUDIT THAT
CALLED FOR MORE RESTRICTIONS ON
TRUMP'S POSTS.
AFTER THE AUDIT WAS RELEASED
FACEBOOK THEN HIRED AN OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL TO LEAD THE
COMPANY'S CIVIL RIGHTS STRATEGY.
I JUST WANT TO REMIND YOU THIS
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH HELPING
BLACK PEOPLE OR